alright Veronica says it's outrageous
one student was banned for five years from all campuses
uh that's true
and he just so happens to be a dear friend and comrade of mine
um and we're gonna have him hop on the mic here on my TikTok
uh this is Bryce and we're gonna let him set the record straight
hey guys it's Bryce Greene
uh organizer with the IU Divestment Coalition
and I was one of the people who was arrested yesterday
I am okay I am safe
I am in contact with uh uh
the jail support system that's pretty robust
so we're all good there
I would like to correct the record on one thing
I was not banned from all campuses
I was only banned from IU Bloomington
this one which is why I'm sitting here on the sidewalk
uh they banned me
although there are people who say that it might not hold up
uh there are people who say that my arrest might not hold up
uh all that is being ran through the legal channels
and I hope to be back on campus soon
now I just wanna say people here are focused on a lot of important issues
but one of the biggest ones is of course 🇵🇸
now why is it that the university decided to send a armoured car
a wall of police with riot shields
body armour machine guns
assault rifle shotguns
choppers in the sky
drones in the sky
and a damn sniper on the roof
now why did they decide to deploy all of this against some students in the park
with some tents
the police they came by
they said disperse your tent and you'll be fine
if not we have all this lethal force at all of our disposal
so does that make sense to you
no it doesn't make sense
unless you understand that they're doing it because they're so threatened
by the student activism in support of 🇵🇸
that they have to bust out this military force
that they have to demoralize people and traumatize people
in order to maintain their authority
in G they call this mowing the lawn
and we get a small
minuscule taste of it here
when they met out military strength
against students who are simply speaking their voice
and it's just designed to terrorize
humiliate and punish people who speak out for the truth and uh
as long as we're intimidated
we'll lose but if we understand that we are powerful
world's ours baby
thank you so much Bryce
for your wise words of encouragement and empowerment of free 🇵🇸